front of the program arcade and the
golden travel guide a second book in the
middle school book series the coin slot
chronicles former national football
league running back seven seasons with
the Jaguars Raiders and Giants good to
see you Rashad Jennings once again
always a pleasure to be on the show do
you sometimes dream that you're playing
you get dream like you know seriously
the dream that your plan that you're
running you're in the middle of a huddle
you're in the middle of a series because
I I sometimes dream like I'm in the
middle of a show I'm wondering if you do
this if you have the same thing no not
yet not yet I'm not
exiting it out as a possibility that may
happen but not yet so you're still okay
are you still hoping to play in the NFL
or you you think you're done with that
I'm done you're done I'll close that
book or close the chapter okay
completely moved on with other endeavors
and things that I've been wanting to do
for a long time okay including you know
we just saw some great stuff from your
foundation some youth camps that you're
doing this book of the three teams you
played for jagz Raiders and Giants who
do you have the closest ties with right
now I definitely the Giants retiring as
a giant I still go back and do a lot of
stuff with them now I actually was just
in New York last week and I got a chance
to go about a facility catch up what
everybody see the familiar faces and
smiles and everybody's face oh it was
good it was good but yeah I'm always
gonna be affiliated with the Giants and
I always go back to Jacksonville
so the first team that believed I mean
it gave me a chance and the Raiders I
still got a lot of respect for Raider
Nation and with the Giants so how is
this gonna play out with with Eli I mean
that the game started off terrific they
got the seven nothing lead then the
Cowboys just steamrolled all over them
the point where Pat Shermer gave Daniel
Jones a little bit of you know of a feat
wedding experience right do we read into
that at all cuz we're reading into every
maneuver that he might be doing or
saying about with Daniel Jones and Eli's
end game of his career what do you think
yeah dad you know what it's it's an
interesting situation I think we all I
kind of looked at it like Eli was gonna
have the moat
more comfortable year than the letter
and the reason why is because there's no
more ghosts in the room where what I
mean by that is there's always been this
ghost right who's gonna replace Eli when
is he gonna retire when is his
replacement coming and to be quite
honest at least my time there in the
last couple years watching away from the
game I haven't seen I don't think Eli's
seen a player come inside that building
that's capable of being the starter and
so as always his ghost who is it gonna
be where is it coming from right it's
prepared for a punch you don't know
where it's coming in here we finally
have that he's physically present and we
know the identity of him makes it easier
I think yeah I think because there's no
more ghosts you actually get to fill it
in with a person hmm and so it's like
all right let me let me let me get back
to just football obviously that wasn't
the outcome I don't think anybody in the
organization that hoped out for you know
give credit where credit is due Cowboys
played lights-out they played very well
you know John is going to be scrappy
this year you know I think they got some
pieces they want to fill in but I think
they got enough weapons to be
competitive and scrap and find and find
plenty of wins throughout the season and
it's not gonna be easy but I think they
got the leadership to do so and we know
that Daniel eventually will be the
starter it's just when do you think it's
just a matter when you know it will be
this year I don't know man it's it's I
cuz it's like it's you looking at it in
and sometimes you feel like Eli is the
is almost the future starting backup
quarterback you know that he's the
backup quarterback they're starting
because of the writing on the wall but I
think Eli can play this whole entire
season well at a high level but anytime
they get a chance when the game game was
out of reach it wasn't so they want to
get Daniel comfortable not preseason
when the game's on the line it's a
different smell in a different or inside
of a regular season yeah cuz I mean cuz
this is totally different
mahomes sat his entire first year up
until week 17 the Chiefs had already
clinched Alex Smith was undeniably gonna
be their quarterback going into the
postseason
and they gave mahomes to start in Denver
so maybe just getting Jones out there in
Dallas you can look around you know he's
gonna have to go there at some point in
his career and hopefully for the Giants
dominate maybe that's why they did it
I just don't envision a scenario where
how about this way I envision a scenario
where the entire season becomes like the
fourth quarter it's over let's just get
him out there yeah and then Eli's just
gonna have to have an earbud in his ear
for the last six games of the season and
I just don't think I don't know if the
the judge he's gonna have to make a
decision whether that end game is
acceptable for yi Lai enough for the
organization to basically look at him
and say this is the way it has to be
yeah in you're right they got to make a
decision at some point and you know my
situation coming from being in
Jacksonville for four years and watching
Blaine Gabbert come in and be the backup
during training camp behind David Gerard
and everybody saying we have to play
blame because he was a first-round draft
pick they try to play him too early and
we see you know the results he didn't
get a chance to flourish like he
probably could have had he had an
opportunity to be groomed he was in
there taking vicious shots you know and
a lot was on the shoulder so I like that
they're trying to groom Daniel Jones
into a futuristic position Rashad
Jennings here former NFL seven years in
the NFL former NFL running back and now
best-selling author philanthropist right
here on the Rich Eisen show what do you
think's going on in the Patriots locker
room right right now and what do you
think's happening look they've got a
Super Bowl champ they got there they are
the Super Bowl champs they've got the
trophy in the case but they've also got
a coach that do their job coach that
week-to-week trying to focus them snap
to snap and in strolls Antonio Brown
with all of this what do you think is
happening in that locker room that's
crazy
that's a circus going on right now but
inside the locker room with Antonio
Brown especially with the most recent
allegations
you have people this is just a true for
the matter you have people that you you
create a judgment about not judging but
you have a judgment about right an
inkling instinct and so when you hear
these type of allegations some people in
the locker room are going to may hear it
and say ah it's no way some may say you
know what it might be some truth to that
some may say yeah he did it I'm gonna
say if he get away with it
all of his allegations but inside that
locker room depending on how Antonio
responds to it it's gonna dictate the
energy of the locker room he's walking
around you know like nothing matters if
he's walking around like I I don't I
care what anybody's thinking anybody's
saying like he's not if he's not being
sensitive to the severity of this
situation it can make people turn their
back on them and not want to support
them and when you don't want to support
your teammates it becomes very cancerous
inside of a locker room no matter how
good the organization this locker I know
you were never inside a Bill Belichick
locker room as a player it just
everybody just everybody people I work
with people I've interviewed it's just a
different community and I blunt it but
something like this do you think could
metastasize inside a locker room like
that it could insert it could be a tick
for sure having its way over time if
it's not addressed and I do get the
mentality of at the end of the day you
have to do your job that's what they say
they're at the end of the day you have
to and I get that and I'm on board for
that but again we're not talking about
you know somebody was just being late to
practice you know do your job this is
this is something that were you have you
have adults in there you have fathers in
there you know you have people that have
sisters you know you have people to have
loving mothers like this is a situation
where you look and it's coupled with all
the other antics that's happened
consecutively within the last year with
one person that makes you say something
something is off some
was skipped you know this somebody was
pushing him through and kept it silent
for a very long time and you know who
was able to kind of not blow the whistle
the whole entire time that's what people
start to build up these ideas of and you
do you have to address it
and whether the whether the coach
addresses in the media whether the
player that hasn't happened they won't
happen that didn't happen earlier today
would you confess about $1 the players
we gonna talk about it in locker room
we're gonna be sitting around the lunch
room like y'all we're setting in the
lunch room this is how this is how it
works we said in the lunch room we're
eating there's TVs we're watching the TV
they may be watching this and they might
be saying you know what we shot on point
because I want to know like in that for
that moment you're not thinking about
the team you're not thinkin about
practice you're not thinking about how
to get an advancement on your opponent
and so bit by bit by bit it can trickle
but um I think they do have great
leadership no doubt about that
that we'll be able to overcome this
situation but again if we don't address
this this sensitivity the sensitivity of
it it could become an issue and fans
will start to Bart Rashad Jennings here
on the show and then just one other item
that seems to be a and this is on the
opposite end of the spectrum of level of
importance but so many people are
talking about the wristwatch on Odell
Beckham's
you're laughing already
Oh Vijay listen this is my god I know I
know he got all of them
listen I mean he's wearing a watch I
think Odell has enough business worth
all to make sure if he does wear a watch
I don't think he's this is just me I
have to talk to him about this but I
don't think he's gonna just wear a watch
just because he likes it that much I
think somebody's gonna pay his fine to
get that brand out because that was
plastered everywhere
well I'm marketing the watch cost did we
find out it the retail the actual retail
price about one about one nine is the
the Price is Right phrase $190,000 yeah
so you've seen this thing right all the
guys my bling-bling all they
to do is sell one of those watches to
somebody right let's just say some
Russian oligarch wants that wristwatch
and for $190,000 comes in them
how many fines is that do we know how
much money he has been fined yet for the
I think he's been fine oh it's calm yet
oh it's coming it's coming
think about it for this will be the
warning sign and this might be the
warning the league was gonna talk to him
and he's already sitting wear it again
Cindy wear it again so you know even if
the fines get increasingly more
expensive you just add it up it might be
half a season would you sell it would
someone watch and they've already got
millions of dollars in advertising
already yeah I'm not I'm not I'm not
advising to do it but I get the business
of it if a listen if a company's willing
to say hey we'll pay your fine wear this
and we'll pay you an additional XY and Z
it's just like them paying you to post
something on Instagram they're trying to
get visibility players are walking
billboards and the more players become
aware of this the NFL is gonna want to
strike down with a larger fine because
it's like we're getting it how much
power a player has so hotels can is open
the door opening the door to a lot and
we'll sift NFL strike down on it or
where players realize the opportunity
and leverage they have of being a
celebrity playing one of the most
watched sports yeah one online sports
book offered odds on what type of watch
o Delaware and week to come on case
you're wondering the are there odds for
a swatch Casio is the second betting
favorite five to one Richard Mille is a
favorite again minus 525 so Rolex is 12
to 1 a Breitling 12 to 1 Omega I watch
not on here that I mean cuz you know why
did text no here's why because as a
professional football player like Odell
Beckham you don't have time to go to the
Genius Bar and sit there
sit there for like two hours waiting for
some genius showing up well yeah we'll
see I I you know have you ever worn
anything like that on the field no okay
have you ever had the need to check the
time while you're on the field wondering
what time it is there's a big there's a
bit at that time what sit down the
distance you know he's fashionable east
alley Odell is a rock star that is true
I mean there's no denying but I mean you
have to win football games in order to
wear watches like that right I mean
technically you would you would you
would want that yes to go hand in glove
Odell shows out he performs he catches
the ball is thrown to him he practices
what do you think it's gonna mean for
him to be back in MetLife Monday night
oh that's gonna be a it's gonna be
everything I mean it's not against the
Giants but he's back in that building
what do you think it's gonna be
emotional for him to be in the opposite
locker room because you know obviously
there's a home team awaiting and so but
he's he's going to be actually in the
same locker room because the Jets are
gonna be in their locker room so he's
gonna be in the Giants locker rooms
right here probably go set at his old
locker in that room from the team that
cut him that talked about him or he in
his in the same it's gonna be it's gonna
be like he might get emotional he might
do something crazy if he score a
touchdown I'm gonna be I'm gonna be
tuned in see what this guy do I know he
gonna do something he might check the
time I don't know but you'll do
something Brockman's already probably
laying a prop base peak on this cuz that
is I mean I didn't think of that
this is great that the away locker room
in MetLife when it's the Jets is the
Giants locker room absolutely so he will
be back in the same room and that is
just you're only gonna conjure up all
sorts of emotion and he will know
literally and figuratively what time it
is
mm-hmm and he would be on the same song
yeah I bet he is a big game you think
ball back in MetLife you think yeah all
right before I let you go coin slot
Chronicles
arkaid and the golden travel guide tell
me about the history of this while
you're doing it and what you get out of
these books sir yeah this is so
rewarding to me anybody knows anything
about me I you know I I always try to I
love creating it is a passion of mine
and I grew up with a reading
comprehension deficit I struggled
academically and you know for for myself
to be in a position
finally to write books that will inspire
kids to read it's it's is it means the
world to me I wrote these books this
series and this is the second book of a
four book series eroded with the desire
to make young males not want to put it
down and is the neatest thing because
I've got a received so many emails from
people you know just acknowledging how
much their kids are reading but one
email tripped me out the most is said
that there they sent their kid to their
room for punishment and usually when I
syndicated a room for punishment they
hear a lot of noise and being loud in
there
yes and they said thirty minutes went by
we didn't hear a peep so we went in and
see what's wrong with them and he was
reading the book that's awesome and he
fell in love with it and so that's what
motivates me but this kid he's
unpretentious he's curious he questions
everything and he runs across this
magical golden token that takes him
across the globe teaching him every life
lesson how to deal with adversity he
gets to go back and travel to the
pyramids he is time tests travel and
truth is what he gets to learn and it's
his fun it's a fun book and he also has
a beautiful sister he moves from
Virginia to New York and he doesn't know
how to necessarily take on the big city
and you got to you get to see a watch a
gullible child teach you so much
it's awesome this is the second one
right this is the second one okay and
the third one will be called in this day
he's given me the exclusive arcade in
the Golden Richard meal watch it's gonna
be it's gonna be great I'm amazing yeah
when the slot receiver chronicles this
slot and I'm on my book tour now and I
tell people you go to Rashad Jennings
DICOM you can go to arcade live in
CENTCOM to figure out how to bring it to
your schools I have a teacher's guide to
this book a teacher syllabus so you can
implement it in your school and I will
come visit and speak to your kids after
they taking the course you're awesome
Rashad Jennings at Rashad Jennings on
Twitter and Instagram Rashad Jennings
foundation.com
come back let's let's talk later on in
the season okay for sure I'll check my
watch you got it he you know what time
is that's Rashad Jennings here on the
Rich Eisen show for more of the Rich
Eisen show tune - audience Channel 239
on DirecTV for free on BR live or
download the Rich Eisen show app